I want to talk about a gig Colin
Brooklyn Nets games as he has for quite
some time
welcome back to the program I Inigo how
are you I'm rich congratulations to you
all right half century 1/2 century life
that's true
thank you Golden Jubilee year welcome
welcome to the club
no no Karen you turn you turn 50 member
this year as well the correct I yes
February February 9th
so I'm February 8th that's so great on
February 9th I felt my my flow was
effect you know what though it's amazing
how how sometimes things can just get
evened out where your flow turning 50
that happens to some of us and I do
think there might be a pill for that on
broadcast that you've been part of I
think I've seen those things and then
all of a sudden let's turn around and
now there's the rant Kyrie Irving the
Nets are the team in town this is it I
mean you read on this is amazing is it a
bizarro world is this just really
happening I heard your rant and I
understand it yes get it with all of
that said I really don't believe that
this was the lone motivation for the
Brooklyn Nets the the motivation for the
Nets has been gearing up to vie for
championships to be a factor to be
relevant and it just so happens that the
two players that the Knicks were most
interested in during the off season
ended up in Brooklyn that is a nice
byproduct but it wasn't the main goal
when Sean marks took over this team it
just so happens that the Knicks are
going through one of their roughest
stretches as a franchise and they're
trying to figure things out and the Nets
have done things the right way do you
need oxygen on the high road like that
I mean under 50
I know sometimes shortness of breath all
the way up there you know it's real
that's true you know that's honest you I
know it is and but you are a native New
Yorker and you said you heard my rant
I'm wondering if you opened up a window
and heard me all the way from Los
Angeles you know you know that the Nets
have been even when they made the finals
in the early aughts Glen apparently they
were capturing the fancy of a young
Jersey I'd named Kyrie Irving but they
never were the game in town ever
and the Knicks knew it and Dolan
operated the way that he operated so for
even the nets to get relevant at the
same time of leapfrogging the Knicks
like that this is the ultimate coup this
is the ultimate coup and I just tip the
cap to the Brooklyn Nets ownership what
is the sense you get from the folks that
you must know very well over the years
of of calling Nets games they must be
jubilant right now yeah I think there's
there's a feeling of that but I actually
think they believe this could happen
this wasn't a pipe dream they talked
about it for three years they certainly
took the necessary steps year after year
after year they didn't skip steps and
that was very much part of Sean marks
whole philosophy and MO that they're
going to do this correctly so while I
think from the outside people are
shocked to the stunned that this
happened I don't necessarily think that
everybody that's been involved in this
is as completely startled by the idea
that people wanted to come and play in
Brooklyn they built a brand new facility
state-of-the-art for some that wouldn't
be enough but you couple that with
having the the right general feeling
around the team the culture that they've
created the family-like atmosphere the
right people in place and all
spots the fact that players around the
league talk the fact that agents around
the league talk this was a confluence of
events that met at the exact right time
in the exact perfect moment for this
franchise but it's not by accident it
didn't happen out of left field this
this has been part of the plan and they
just happened to execute it I an eagle
here on the Rich Eisen show been calling
nets games since 1994 do you remember
who was on the floor the first time were
you at Brendan Byrne Arena what was your
first game Colin I was in Houston the
Rockets were receiving their
championship trophies the Nets head
Kenny Anderson they had Derrick Coleman
Chris Morris don't leave out Bernard man
German don't you dare leave out the know
in German a noble beef but knowing
Benjamin was there shinbone the late
Dwayne chinses was there Jason Williams
Chris child's it was a cavalcade Rick
Mahorn it it was it was a team that I
will never forget and really a bunch of
good people I must say breaking in it at
a young age with with that squad they
were very welcoming but it's a far cry
from swamps right now and look let's
face it rich you know having grown up in
this area this doesn't happen if it's in
New Jersey it doesn't know Brooklyn part
of this equation played a huge role
immense role in Kyrie Irving and Kevin
Durant deciding that this was the right
spot and the Kyrie stuff that's that's
real I've had some time with Kyrie here
and there through the years and one
particular instance where we had a long
conversation 45-minute conversation
about him growing up in New Jersey a net
fan going to games working his way down
to closer seats because they happen to
be open des Christ those nights right
and how curious he was about the dynamic
on that team with Kidd and with Carter
and with Kerry Kittles and Van Horn and
Kenyon Martin and Richard Jefferson
these were questions from and all and
be a player but it was like I was
talking to a young fan that that's the
level of engagement he had and
discussing the old New Jersey Nets so
this also happen to be part of that
confluent instead you just happened to
get a player in Kyrie Irving maybe one
of the rare players that actually grew
up a niche that I can tie a needle here
on the show I just like I still can't
believe it I can't believe it
I seriously I can't believe it the Nets
I don't want to I just it's it's just
what is it like there I assume you're
calling in for are you in New York
are you in the area right now in the New
York area okay so then what's what's it
like are people just losing their minds
Colin radio shows and just going crazy I
mean what is it like in the area to see
I think though for Knicks fans it's it's
been an unfortunate acceptance of their
fate I can't even say that Knicks fans
were flabbergasted by what happened
they've almost come to expect it at this
point the way things have gone the last
few years the fact that it is the Nets
the fact that they have always looked at
the Nets franchise as a complete
afterthought a non-factor yes that that
plays into it to some degree but I think
it's it's deeper than that for Knicks
fans it's just been so much pain and
agony now overtime from a fan
perspective that they're they're almost
numb at this point to what's happening
and things really do need to change and
I think by the way for the NBA I hope
they do change and I hope for this
rivalry it changes that the Knicks and
nets are playing quality basketball at
the same time both teams to create a
legitimate rivalry instead of the one
that is you know a bit of a unfortunate
media creation because it just hasn't
been an actual organic thing did you run
out of oxygen again I mean is that
what's happened right there cuz this is
look I mean cuz III remember
driving around for the Staten Island
advance in the early 90s listening to
you do the 2020 sports flash is on WFAN
and had your own show see you you know I
mean this is in your DNA you know this
you and talk about her numb this hurts
this is it's over I mean there's all
gonna be a whole new generation of
youngsters that know the nets for being
the Durant Kyrie Nets which we're
assuming is going to be terrific and
short of Barrett blossoming into some
sort of like what Jason Tatum type young
third overall pick right or just having
something about him and that they're
able to create through their own draft
and if you want front office savvy that
Dolan doesn't get involved in the Knicks
are just gonna be struggling hoping
pining for Yanis and creating the space
for it now in 2021 this is just a
bizarro scenario I am and they'll
they'll be yearning for coverage from
the SI a from the stand if they
credential them you know I don't know if
they're pissed at the coverage I you
know so the nets actually might get some
coverage any of that coverage in 92 it's
coming it but here's the thing is that
it's it's gonna it's gonna be an
adjustment for a lot of longtime New
Yorkers it's gonna be an adjustment and
it's comin and it's deserved the Nets
deserve all the coverage all the buzz
all the attention all the celebrities
I'm wondering who the first celebrity to
to go like is Spike Lee gonna show up
there in a big night like is you know
like you know who's gonna be the first
celebrity to actually go across the
bridge that's known for going to Knicks
games to go to a Mets game
I wonder what I've heard I don't want to
give too much away I heard I guess I can
say it right okay it's Mel Brooks
that's an odd choice iron
that's an odd I mean
Dustin Hoffman I mean this is hey jay-z
better get ready to have some company
out there who are the other celebrities
who have been there at Nets games like
regulars like real regulars real folks
who've really put in the real regulars
yes real regulars we're going to be part
of the new Nets celebrity row Morgan
Fairchild no you're getting conflation
it's the oxygen again Paul Lynde for the
block oh my god I think they're ready to
open their arms to of course any
celebrity that's interested in making
the jump Ethan Hawke in recent years has
emerged okay as an F Matt formerly a
Knick fan but okay the Brooklyn allure
has brought him to Barclays Center so I
think I think Ethan's going to be a big
part of it do you have news to break -
yeah yeah and breaking news a Paul Lynde
died in 1982
so I guess his seats available I'm it
was a New Jersey net game that's my
guess what it was probably on New York
in that game I know that's true yeah
then that boy the New Jersey Nets were
born in 77 it's crazy and this is truly
a remarkable transformation you're gonna
be at the mic this is got to excite you
I understand that we have we're all
folks but you know what we're
professionals but this has got to be you
got to be fired up for this rich my my
phone is ringing off the hook I've had
to hire a personal assistant my life
dramatically in the last 36 hours no
kidding okay very good
yeah what do you want your question for
no man even practicing reads this
offseason
yeah the daily thing so you know some
people are in the Transcendental
Meditation I just practice Reid's doing
right now that's what you're doing
that's what I do I mean I have some time
off to myself and this is what I
dedicate myself to the games just get in
the way my read that's right that's
right
yeah bluebloods just doesn't promote
itself but I'm also talking about you
know net stuff like hey KD confidential
the name of a new episode you know
Kairi confidential look I'm being
serious in a way here too and I know
that you've been very kind to not try
and set me off again on but this is
coming there's a whole like the Yankee
showed what they could do with a major
roster in their own network and people
focusing in it the Nets world is about
to crack wide open Durant and Kyrie
chose them
they chose each other and chose them
they are coming to New York and folks
are gonna have to get used to the Nets
being the team to watch and talk about
and it's gonna be the hottest ticket and
it's gonna be the spot to be and you can
do all sorts of programming around it
all sorts of stuff and you're the you're
the voice of it so it's gonna be great
for you Congrats on yeah in all
seriousness um I am really excited for
it I think the fan base that has stuck
with the franchise through thick and
thin deserves it and I am telling you
this from a little bit of an insider's
perspective the people within the
organization also deserve it they've
done it the correct way everything they
said when Sean marks took the job he has
lived up to and I don't think they're
done I don't think that this is it that
they had their monumental moment and
they just ride off into the sunset he's
a competitive guy and he's looking at
this not as a nice way of validating the
team but of trying to win the whole
enchilada
and if you
you have that backing from ownership
which they do you you can do serious
damage if you have smart people in place
Kenny Atkinson as well he gets himself a
talent lead and roster and he's got a
real special way with players and a
bedside manner that has already proven
to be effective so sky's the limit and
this team is enjoying their moment in
the Sun but I don't think they're
resting on any kind of Laurel already
went to the jackpot and they swung for
the fences and they hit it out of the
party sure did and then and then again
whatever it looks like next year then
there's the excitement of Durant coming
back which we're assuming is gonna
happen in the following season so a team
that made the playoffs with DeAngelo
Russell just got Kyrie at that spot run
it back see what it looks like and then
Durant joins I mean good good Lord and
then as you say is smart aggressive
group that doesn't have an owner that
treats people like their objects as
opposed to customers I've seen I can't
go there but you know what I mean like
it definitely works and I'm excited for
you I on I really am and for the team
I'm sorry I have to do some rehearsal
time for God friended me so well I'll
tell you what God fronted the Nets
coming this fall coming this fall
thanks for the call on you take carries
right back out signing for more of the
Rich Eisen show tune - audience Channel
239 on DirecTV for free on BR Live or
download the Rich Eisen show app